hey guys welcome to tech tuesday it's
not tuesday but what i do have is some
tech the new gopro hero4 finally was
able to get my hands on one of them
so to do my unboxing today i've got a
new really fancy unboxing
wow don't touch the blade it's a really
sharp knife but i'm quite pumped about
it because it's really pretty usually
when i do my unboxings i i burn
the box open and i don't think we're
gonna do that today i don't even think i
actually need this knife wow that's it
cool really useful unfortunately i
ordered my gopro from gopro.com the
first second that it was available and
they proceeded to not send me the gopro
but they sent me all my accessories that
i ordered which was very nice but it was
a tease it was a really awful tease i
was like yes my gopro's here and i
opened it up and there was no pro so
last night me and my sister ran all
around california basically trying to
find
the gopro hero4 black edition
and guess what we found we found it many
miles traveled
let me just open this up already
let's get to them let's get real good
we will use the knife chop chop chop
chop chop
oh there's a nice little tab here to
pull
thank you
you look really nice
you look almost identical to the
previous version but it's what's inside
that counts
we'll use some little stickers got some
directions
i don't like directions
battery
adhesive adapters and another back door
housing which is open so not waterproof
and that's all we have in this box
let's
take a little peek
at the actual gopro itself i think my
favorite part of this entire unboxing is
this little piece of
plastic that says
remove
hopefully they made these cases easier
to open because
if you're a girl let me tell you how
much it sucks to have fingernails and
try to open this
seem to be a little bit easier
it smells really fresh i kind of wish
they would have made it black if you
call
the hero black i would like for the
gopro to be black the blackout housing
is probably one of my favorite
accessories that gopro has ever made
here it is
oh
a new place for the battery which is now
on the bottom
i kind of like that if i put this in the
right way just like a little puzzle
piece oh wow so there's a new little
settings button here on the side i'm
hoping that the audio was a lot better
that's the biggest complaint that i have
about most of the gopros especially the
older versions the audio sucks a lot of
these little cameras it's so hard to
pack a good microphone into them
so pumped i am like a child a child on
christmas
all right this is i can't show you i
can't show you what i'm doing so let's
see what we can do here
this is so little
okay let's test it out here's the first
video am i already recording no
hey guys so i'm making a little video
here on the new gopro hero4
black edition
quite pumped about it that's it now i
need to go do something really exciting
because this is a really boring gopro
video
so since gopro didn't send my actual
gopro they did send my accessories so i
got the new lcd touch screen since the
black version doesn't have an lcd screen
on the back but the silver version does
to unlock the screen
slide down and hold
this is so much easier to see the
settings this way
the settings screen on the front is so
small i'm like i don't know what your
what you want me to do they have three
different gopro models so obviously i
have a black version which it shoots up
to 4k 30 frames a second and at 1080p
you can go up to 120 frames a second i
think a lot of people are gonna be going
for the silver version which will shoot
up to 1080p at 60 frames a second but
the best part about it is it actually
has an lcd screen built into the back so
you won't need the extra lcd attachment
and the last addition to the gopro 4
lineup is just the base model gopro
what's kind of crazy about this is it's
actually black so it kind of drives me
nuts this one is called black and that
one's not called
it's just
gopro it's 130 bucks you could shoot
1080p at 30 frames a second and 720p at
60 frames a second so if you've never
had a gopro before and you're not
looking to spend as much as the high end
definitely check out the black
gopro that's not called the black gopro
here's a little side-by-side comparison
of the three and the four
side-by-side that's why they call it a
side-by-side comparison previously the
battery
was inserted on the back and now it's on
the bottom and it looks like the
microphone actually used to be on the
side and now it's on the top is that
correct or am i making it up i think i'm
correct hey guys just a little editor's
note here i wanted to show you the app
really quick it's all connected to wi-fi
we've got you all set up and it's
looking pretty good oh my gosh what's on
my gopro this is basically the only way
that i ever even use my gopro because
you can
change the settings so easily actually
let's change you to 120 and give you a
test
i'll also put a link in the description
so you guys can go check out all of the
specs there's a lot of different specs
that i'm not going to bore you with here
you guys can do some comparison shopping
and see which one is right for you i
like they move the light over here great
looks really great gopro you did a great
job as for my other accessories that i
got i got it's this dual battery charger
and if you're a gopro fan and you've had
gopros in the past you know the battery
life on these things is
not that great came with an extra
battery so thank you really appreciate
it and one of these which i got with
this
i don't remember what it's called this
is like the floating selfie
arm floating i don't know what they
caught it online but i've done a lot of
water activities with my gopro and my
biggest fear is losing it into the ocean
really lightweight too and what i like
that this came with it helps you tighten
this screw so that this won't move
around very much like i'm just going to
carry this in my purse from now on
hopefully i can go do something more
exciting than sitting here talking to
you and filming in front of my face but
stay tuned for more videos i'm really
excited about the new gopro lineup so
let me know what you guys think let me
know what you think of competitors in
this space which i'd be interested to
hear and i'd be interested to try them
out as well i've tried a lot of cameras
and so far nothing has really come close
to gopro granted they might be cheaper
but sometimes you definitely do pay for
the quality you do pay for the name and
you pay for all the amazing accessories
that come with it i did buy this so this
isn't sponsored i'm just a huge gopro
fan anyway i'm gonna go thank you guys
for watching i hope that you enjoyed my
unboxing with my new knife happy tech
tuesday it's not tuesday i know bye